the most important issue that ministers
were discussing today as part of the
upcoming European Council meeting we're
related to migration we have been as the
presidency in close cooperation is the
Commission and external action service
repair a roadmap identifying further
actions regarding migration poles
updated roadmap will be presented 20
p.m. Council we have agreed on a renewed
European Union internal security
strategy for next 5 years already and I
think that this strategy is very timely
to address three priority areas fight
against terrorism and radicalization
organized crime and cyber crime today
also General Affairs Council had debate
on the former Yugoslavia public of
Macedonia and we have adopted relevant
console conclusions we stressed that
political parties have to honor the June
second and June nineteenth agreements
and we also underlined repeatedly
already the importance of containing
continuation of reforms in rule of law
area including fundamental rights to
this shortly the media freedom elections
corruption and the authorization of
state executions